[Music]
welcome back to science click today
electromagnetic waves
imagine a particle that has an electric
charge
due to its charge the particle generates
an electric field around it
this electric field is static it does
not vary over time because the charge is
Motionless
imagine now that we accelerate this
charge
as it accelerates the particle requires
a certain speed according to special
relativity this speed leads to the
appearance of a magnetic field around it
the electric and magnetic fields are
intimately linked they are two
components of one same object the
electromagnetic field and they will
therefore interact with each other
in particular the magnetic field which
has just appeared will disturb the
electric field this disturbance of the
electric field will in turn disturb the
magnetic field step by step the electric
and magnetic fields will influence each
other and vary in turn through this
Mutual disturbance process
the movement that has been imposed on
the particle will propagate throughout
space spreading at the speed of light
through the electric and magnetic fields
this phenomenon is called an
electromagnetic wave
depending on the acceleration of the
particle the electromagnetic wave will
be more or less energetic waves can thus
be classified into several categories of
energy depending on the frequency at
which they oscillate we find of course
visible light with the different colors
of the rainbow but not only that
infrared ultraviolet microwaves x-rays
radio waves or gamma rays all these
waves that we cannot see with our bare
eyes are also electromagnetic waves
the vast majority of this radiation is
invisible to us but thanks to current
Technologies we can design special
cameras and instruments to detect them
or even emit them
this is what is used for microwave ovens
telecommunications and other remote
transmission systems but also in
astronomy and space telescopes
astronomers observe the universe with
different types of waves because this
allows them to get a much broader and
more detailed image of the cosmos
compared with only using visible light
electromagnetic waves are present
everywhere
as soon as charged particles move change
speed or Direction They generate such
waves
moreover all objects that have a
temperature emit such radiation
to understand it is necessary to look at
the microscopic scale
the temperature of an object corresponds
to the agitation of its atoms atoms are
made up of two parts a nucleus of
positive electrical charge and a cloud
of electrons of negative charge when
vibrating the atoms shake their electron
clouds these behave somewhat as if they
were connected by a rubber band
all these electrical charges are
therefore constantly accelerating and
changing direction the atoms will thus
emit electromagnetic waves which become
more energetic as the temperature of the
object Rises
the human body for example whose
temperature is around 37 degrees Celsius
is constantly emitting infrared
radiation these waves are not visible to
our eyes we cannot see other humans
glowing but we can detect them with
thermal imaging cameras
a very interesting feature of
electromagnetic waves is their
polarization as we have seen previously
electron clouds in atoms behave as if
they were connected to the nucleus by a
rubber band
when atoms are agitated electron clouds
vibrate around nuclei in all directions
and the waves that are generated have a
very chaotic shape this type of wave is
said to be non-polarized
imagine sending a wave of this shape
onto a Charged particle
the particle will undergo a force
because it interacts with the electric
and magnetic fields that make up the
wave it will start to vibrate like the
wave and therefore like the atoms which
produced it
it is in this way for instance that the
sun can warm the Earth's atmosphere
despite being millions of kilometers
away its heat is transmitted from its
surface via electromagnetic waves
through the vacuum of space
[Music]
however it is possible to make atoms
vibrate in a much more controlled way
the electron clouds can vibrate in one
of three possible ways
let's imagine a marble placed on a table
and which is connected to a nail using a
very tight rubber band
let's imagine now that we launched the
marble
we observed that its trajectory almost
often form ellipses and sometimes either
straight lines or perfect circles
within atoms electron clouds are
attracted to the nucleus in the same way
that the marble is attracted to the nail
thus they will also vibrate in one of
these three possible ways and generate
very clean electromagnetic waves which
are said to be polarized with either
rectilinear elliptical or circular
polarization
radio antennas for instance cause atoms
to oscillate along the axis of the
antenna
they thus generate very clean waves with
a rectilinear polarization
the polarization of light is not
directly visible to the naked eye our
eyes are only sensitive to light
intensity but not to the direction of
the fields
nonetheless this is a crucial property
which influences how light interacts
with objects
in particular there exist filters that
can absorb certain polarizations
these filters are called polarizers
they are used for 3D cinema technology
in particular where it is possible to
project two images simultaneously with
two different polarizations and to
design glasses with polarizing lenses
which will only let one of the two
polarizations pass
finally as electromagnetic waves are
waves they evolve in space in accordance
to very specific principles
like all waves they add on to each other
if we superimpose two crests we will
obtain a Crest twice as high whereas if
we superimpose a wave with its exact
opposite the two will cancel out
perfectly
this first principle of wave
superposition is called interference
wave interference is notably the cause
of diffraction which is observed when a
wave encounters a small obstacle or
passes through a very narrow slit
as we saw previously when it moves
through a transparent medium made up of
atoms an electromagnetic wave generates
a force on the electron clouds so as to
set them in motion these vibrations
within the atoms will themselves emit
waves which propagate in all directions
and which share roughly the same
characteristics as the initial wave
thus even if we send light from a
specific Direction the medium diffuses
it in all directions this is called
scattering
the Earth's atmosphere is a very good
example to illustrate scattering the
atmosphere itself doesn't really have a
color
the sun however constantly sends
electromagnetic radiation towards our
planet and in particular white light
which is made up of all the colors of
the rainbow
as these waves pass the atoms that make
up the air vibrate and thus scatter
light in all directions this phenomenon
is as powerful as the wave is energetic
red yellow and green colors correspond
to relatively weak waves while bluish
tints have more energy
as such it is the blue Waves that make
electrons vibrate the most and therefore
scatter light that's why the sky is blue
finally when we send an electromagnetic
wave on a material for instance water
part of the wave continues its path
through the material while another part
bounces back we say that the wave is
partly refracted and partly reflected
let's start by looking at the phenomenon
of reflection
if we shine light on a conductive
material like the metal of a mirror some
electrons on the surface are not bound
to atoms this is what gives the metal
its ability to conduct electricity
as the light wave passes the
electromagnetic fields will set these
free electrons in motion
electric currents appear on the surface
and these currents perfectly reproduce
the shape of the incident wave
the movements of the electrons on the
surface will in turn generate a wave
similar to the incident wave but which
propagates on both sides of the surface
this wave corresponds to the reflected
wave
when we look at ourselves in a mirror it
is this wave generated by the electric
currents in the metal that we see
on the bottom the wave generated by the
electric current is perfectly opposite
to the incident wave the two therefore
interfere canceling out the initial wave
following on from this we see that the
portion of the wave that managed to
cross the surface of the water oddly
seems to propagate in a slightly
different direction and to move more
slowly this is called refraction
refraction is a complex phenomenon which
is due once again to the superposition
of several waves
as the incident wave passes the atoms
and their electron clouds start to
vibrate in the water so as to emit New
Waves which add on to the initial wave
but these new waves are slightly offset
from the incident wave thus slowing down
the light beam as a whole
it is important to understand that the
speed of light in itself has not changed
the electromagnetic field always reacts
at the same speed and each of the Waves
generated by the atoms travels at the
speed of light
the light beam however which is the sum
of all the waves does slow down due to
all these interferences
a beam of light therefore propagates
more slowly in certain materials than in
a vacuum and it is possible for
particles to exceed the speed of light
or rather the propagation of a light
wave within a material
just like the bang that occurs when an
airplane exceeds the speed of sound this
phenomenon results in the appearance of
a flash of light this is the charinkov
effect
it is a method currently used by
scientists to detect neutrinos
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]